Antonio Brown very much wants back in
the National Football League now there
are impediments first of all the NFL
investigating him for a sexual assault
and rape lawsuit that was filed last
September and then there was an incident
after that where he allegedly harassed
via text message someone else who had
made a complaint about him to si.com and
then there was the arrest last month in
Miami when someone showed up with
furniture and other belongings that were
being moved from California he refused
to pay for a rock of the truck allegedly
guy came back and he assaulted the
driver allegedly beyond what the NFL is
going to do or not do with Antonio Brown
he has to find a team and it sounds like
he wants to go back to Pittsburgh
shereen posting the apology on Instagram
to Ben Roethlisberger I never realized
how good I had it got caught up in my
emotion with everyone coming after me I
really apologize for my actions
sincerely man it's never been another
connection like what we done in the past
decade I appreciate you well you know
first of all I guess it's fitting that a
guy who destroyed his career on social
media would be trying to resurrect it
there he needs to have the conversation
with Ben Roethlisberger and and look I
after all the crap he pulled last year
and and I'm a big fan of forgiving
forgetting and moving on in a way that
benefits everyone that's a lot to expect
Ben Roethlisberger to overlook I mean he
was public enemy number one in the eyes
of Antonio Brown and he was the guy that
Brown targeted to get out of Pittsburgh
I don't think one year or later Ben
Roethlisberger is going to be ready to
practice t-shirts gonna be willing to
take him back I think this is an
organization too that held on to a be
knowing what a great player he was but
now we see exactly what went on in
Pittsburgh and how much they had to keep
him behind the scenes not letting it out
that's what's most amazing to me that
none of this ever came out until his
last year in Pittsburgh and and now we
know there was a lot of stuff going on
there and it it wasn't always good in
Pittsburgh so I don't think the
organization would be able to forgive
him and definitely not Ben
Roethlisberger only a year after this
happened and is he
Sisir I think that's the biggest
question I mean with Johnny Manziel you
saw this over and over and over again I
apologize it sounds great it sounds
sincere and then two days later a week
later a month later two months later
whatever it is it's back to the same old
thing so has baby gotten the help he
need it he's needed let's hope so let's
hope this is real but until we see it
for a long period of time I think
there's always those doubts yeah what it
is with Antonio Brown is he apologizes
and then he assumes that's gonna fix
everything and when it doesn't he
eventually gets frustrated and says or
does something that requires another
future apology and that's been the cycle
and look once it all blew up last year
it became obvious there were a lot of
things that happen behind the scenes in
Pittsburgh with Antonio Brown that we
didn't know about and we found out about
some of them but when we had you Juche
miss you stir at the Super Bowl I asked
him point-blank is what we've seen out
of Antonio Brown over the last year is
that similar to what you guys dealt with
behind the scenes or is this different
and juju said this is different this is
different and we're all concerned about
Antonio Brown at this point so I think
above and beyond whether or not a simple
apology posted on social media is going
to get Ben Roethlisberger to forgive and
forget there are deeper issues here that
need to be addressed and we've yet to
see anything that makes me believe
Antonio Brown has taken that aspect of
it seriously any time he's asked the
question he's got a flippant response
you know how's your mental health do you
need help well we all need help well
some need more than others and there's
nothing wrong with it there's nothing to
be embarrassed about
look something's happened to this guy
over the course of the last few years
and playing in the NFL is stressful
everybody thinks it's glamorous and it's
just money no it is a stressful
existence and you have a lot of people
who are counting on you and I think the
older a player gets and the more he
realizes the end is coming and they
bring in a guy who is the next to me I
think that was the genesis of the whole
resentment of Jewish miss you stir when
they made him the MVP in 2018 that was
the clearest message yet the Antonio
Brown and at some point we're gonna be
done with you you're not gonna be able
to play anymore and you better get ready
for it I think that's what caused him to
blow up at the Steelers in the first
place
Shareen so I think there's a lot there
that he needs to process
understand and he needs help from some
external source to help him understand
who he is where he is and why he's done
the things he's done until he does that
he's never going to be able to truly
apologize and make amends you know I I
think this is one of the greatest
receivers in the NFL over the last
however many years we want to talk about
however long he's been in the league and
it's gonna be very sad if he never plays
again and I'm one who thinks he's never
gonna play again in the NFL and if he
doesn't it's gonna be one of the most
wasted careers we've ever seen because
he won't go into the Hall of Fame and I
do think he has Hall of Fame talent
here's a question Mike it say he does
somehow make up with Ben Roethlisberger
say he meets with him whatever and he go
and he goes Ben Roethlisberger goes the
Steelers and says I want this guy back
we've made up if you're the Steelers do
you bring him back yeah look it's more
than Ben Roethlisberger that needs to be
made up with you better be sure that
he's gonna get along with you just miss
Shuster and you've just better be damn
sure that you can rely on this guy and
you're gonna want it to be different and
there's no reason to think it is going
to be different I just think that no
matter how desperate the Steelers are to
try to rebuild this thing I'd rather you
know they say the devil that you know is
better than the devil you don't know I'd
rather have the devil I don't know I'd
rather take my chances with someone that
I haven't seen the worst and dealt with
the worst and made excuses and look the
other way because I was intoxicated by
his talent I'd rather try a different
approach all together I don't think he's
gonna play again either too much has
happened the moment he posted the video
of berating the mother of his children
and yelling at the cops to me that was
the moment that no one's gonna deal with
this guy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports